hey guys it's Monday October 17th I'm
Mary filling in for regular host Jess
McDonald to bring you gamespot news
today Rockstar released two teaser
images to what is very likely the next
red dead game well it's it's either that
or it's a really really poorly timed
western GTA 5 update nobody wants that
yeah it's got to be read dead 2 or red
dead 3 depending on you know how you
look at it the image which has no
caption but his oozing Red Dead style
shows off seven characters in silhouette
form whether this is a tease for
multiplayer remains to be seen it
shouldn't surprise anyone that a sequel
is likely red dead redemption was adored
by critics and it shipped more than 14
million copies Strauss Zelnick the CEO
of rockstars parent company told
investors to think about red dead as a
permanent franchise like GTA so that's
all we know officially so here come the
assumptions the studio's twitter
facebook and official website now all
prominently feature the new red rock
star logo which went live Sunday at 9am
the fancy new image you see before you
was released this morning at 9am so it
seems possible we're gonna get another
taste of red dead tomorrow maybe 9am
stay tuned for the latest many of the
beloved video game characters you've
played over the years are voiced by the
same group of people a group of people
that might be going on strike this month
imagine a voice you've home in SL Wow
sonicated I guess I think goodbye like
different a bit weird the guild
representing voice actors has now
announced that a strike might occur on
october 21st if an agreement is not
agreed upon in the game industry the
guild named sag-aftra and no i will not
be explaining what those letters mean
says that its package of proposals is
not loaded with crazy demands several
prominent voice actors have spoken out
in support of authorizing a strike
including roger craig smith you might
remember him from batman or assassin
creed how about jennifer hale from Mass
Effect or perhaps wil wheaton you know
who will heat miss sag-aftra said actors
should strike against 11 companies
including some of gaming's biggest
players like Activision
a take two and WB games the video game
industry has responded to the strike
date with its own statement Scott J
whittlin who worked for the law firm
representing the industry in
negotiations said the industry has
negotiated in good faith for the past 18
months the industry is quote/unquote
deeply disappointed by the strike date
announcement fight fight fight fight
fight additionally he said that the
existing collective bargaining agreement
has a no strike provision which allows
development on most current and near
future games to continue development
unabated fight fight fight fight fight
fight fight check back on the latest on
this voice actor showdown finally there
was a new study released that showed how
gamers feel about micro transactions and
DLC and the results might surprise you
the study titled DLC and micro
transaction purchasing found that among
the entire US population of men and
women aged 13 to 54 twenty-eight percent
have purchased extra content in the past
three months males and teens were the
primary drivers of purchases suckers
additionally the study found that people
are more likely to spend money on micro
transactions that's twenty-three percent
than downloadable content sixteen
percent as you might imagine price is
the leading factor when people are
thinking about spending money on micro
transactions and DLC here are some of
the main takeaways from the survey is
written by NPD close to half of non
purchasers of micro transactions are not
willing to spend any money on them
forty-eight percent felt the content
wasn't worth the extra expense half of
non DLC purchases stated the DLC wasn't
worth the money sixteen percent believe
the extra content should have been
included in the full game price however
and this might shock you attitudes
towards microtransactions specifically
are mostly positive with the majority
seventy-seven percent claiming to like
that micro transactions allow them to
extend their enjoyment of a particular
game sixty-eight percent believe the pay
to win aspect of micro transactions
within gaming is unfortunate that's one
word for it apparently this survey
didn't let you fill your own word in
there as you are aware micro
transactions are everywhere in the case
of GTA 5 the game's micro transactions
for GTA online have reportedly brought
in more than 500 million
revenue one game that apparently won't
have them is resident evil 7 what do you
think about microtransactions you like
them you let me know and that's all i
have for you today but check back again
tomorrow for the latest have a good one